[Applauso]
[Musica]
già abbiamo in viaggio stia montando
direzione castello e ci aspettano sette
ore di viaggio in macchina
a voi piace di viaggi in macchina o
preferite i viaggi in aereo scrivetelo
nei commenti
abbiamo tutte le essenziali per il
viaggio in macchina cappellino crema
solare per non scottarsi nella borraccia
termina così rimane fresca per un sacco
di ore e parasole e voi verrete insieme
a noi arriveremo stanotte al castello in
effetti sarà un po più inquietante
vedere il castello per la prima volta di
no testeremo la prima notte nel castello
e voi sarete sempre con noi è bellissimo
perché sembra che voi state vivendo in
viaggio con noi
vedo l'ora di mangiare che bello siamo
ragazzi siamo stanchissimi soprattutto
vitale anche artisti appena arriverà
vitali di mangeranno le mura del
castello il ponte del castello che
cos'altro
stiamo arrivando al castello abbiamo
molto in salita ha detto capisse stiamo
entrando nella foresta che arriva al
castello
leo per arrivare per fortuna non è
proprio buio buio buio c'è un pochettino
di luce la strada è un pò strada è tutta
in salita io ti ho fatto sono in alto
questo il capitello
no
eccoci ragazzi e con il castello ora
entriamo stiamo entrando nel castello
come sarà
ciao
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ciao ragazzi
parla passa voce perché notte fonda
stiamo per entrare dentro al castello
abbia un po di paura perché è un pò
inquietante di no però è bellissimo
guardate
wow è bellissimo è un vero castello
dobbiamo ora andare nella nostra stanza
la nostra dimora del cartello che sopra
queste star
speriamo che non ci sia niente di strano
dentro cosa troveremo nella stanza
secondo voi
abbiamo il nostro orticello
altro bellissimo a stare in un vero
castello e ora entriamo nella nostra
stanza la nostra stanza si chiama da il
ponte levatoio
eccoci qua qua possiamo parlare a voce
un pochino più alta perché anche se è
notte fonda siano chiusi nella nostra
stanza
facciamo un rum tour ma che stai facendo
sto vedendo se c'è qualche cosa da
mangiare un po di un pasto del dei primi
del progetto tutte queste potrebbe
esserci qualcosa di pericoloso ma dentro
no no è vuoto bene o male non c'e nessun
fantasma l'arbitro beh effetti non
metterti ad aprire tutto perché potrebbe
uscire qualcosa di strano allora nel
frigo il problema il problema che il
frigo è vuoto
mi dispiace per te se vuoi di
rimangiarsi il ponte levatoio e i pezzi
di pietra nel cartello un po croccante
ma vabbè si può fare esploriamo l'hanno
trattato di cartello contro promozionata
ios 3 non vero castello d'oro sempre
studiato di vivere in un castello intero
castello e fan tutti allora qua abbiamo
un divano grandissimo evitare se russa a
dormire acqua cercherà di mangiarsi il
cuscino
io in realtà ho visto qualcos'altro che
si può mangiare cioccolatini vista pizza
rubando senza dirmi niente lascia di qua
continuiamo il nostro di una voce non
capite 20 abbiamo il titano di quella
specie di armadio strano un altro armadi
le cd alte sbocco in quanto sembra che
potresti nasconderci un paio di persone
cosa è un paio di persone colata terzo è
bellissimo adoro tutto e poi riemen di
tutto in piedi 31 il soffitto in legno
sono queste due tende per chiudere qua
non so che cosa sia forse nasconde
qualcosa che cos'è una finestra una
finestra così piccola si è una finestra
piccolino si infortuna finestra piccoli
non vedo niente niente ci credo ma non
c'è niente da fare una finestra su che
cos'è una feritoia giusta una feritoia
infatti le feritoie nei castelli al
tempo venivano usate per colpire i
nemici per quello sono così strette così
non potevano essere colpiti dai nemici
mi potevano colpire i nemici ci siamo
[Musica]
guardate
ecco qua non vedrete potete vedere un
pochettino dell'albero che sei fuori dal
però no non c'è niente da mangiare mi
dispiaceva linee anzi qualcosa di
interessante perché posso fare un pezzo
di legno
forse prima cuocere una finestra più
grande e poi è stata murata per qualche
motivo dispero sicuramente in questo
castello si sono un pò di segreti che
modelli di cinema svelare comunque
continuiamo il tour e dalla nostra
storia e così sono due tende poi abbiamo
questa colonna
questo è un po già cibo per vitale una
finestra a finestra ho paura ad aprirla
pop apriamola alla fine poi c'è questa
poltrona da re o regina molto molto
comoda amboy abbiamo un affresco con il
singolo che potrebbe significare
qualcosa al fresco
sì questa è la famosa torta della nonna
evitato al terreno è fatta così
arrotonda il disegno di fiore ad ortona
non l'ha fatta con le mele il pinoli e
questo che ci abbia un'altra comodissima
poltrona del reprobo della casina e
abbiamo due sedie che sono delle sedie
medievali e cioè se ti e belle ma
scomodissimo
rivali se qualcosa si dice qualcosa
gioco cosa guardia di guardare cibo e
niente è impossibile che c'è un
telecomando dentro ad un cartello e il
telecomando del ponte levatoio per
alzare o abbassare il porter ma sempre
il comando di una tv è la tv che
effettivamente sia il telecomando di una
tv non volevo il telecomando del ponte
levatoio da tempo volevo a chi
coccodrilli le trovate qua c'è una
bellissima pista forse poi ora state
vedendo noi e rifletti
ma in realtà c'è una bellissima vista
verso il cortile del castello che domani
vedremo meglio con la luce del sole
potremo meglio esploreremo meglio il
castello e filo d'acqua un po si può
vedere guardate priamo alla finestra
scorti castello bene ora che abbiamo
fatto il rum tour cosa ne pensate vi
piace la nostra stanza in questo
cartello ovviamente poi domani vi faremo
fare anche il castello turrito vendere
meglio anche il cappello ma ora vediamo
cosa c'è alla fine tra si potrebbe dire
la finestra misteriosa non vedo l'ora di
vedere che cosa si trattava la finestra
secondo tempo stessi e là dietro una
vista sulle torri del castello i
cavalieri gr difendono cavalieri che la
difende
e ancora e poi di corazzate lui non fai
cosa sarebbe la cosa più inquietante
volete io lo presti questa finestra ci
fosse una persona che ci guarda così
messo mai inquietante vero secondo voi
cosa c'è oltre questa finestra
scrivetelo nei commenti prima che io la
prima a fine aprile
vediamo se indovinate lasciate anche un
bel mi piace sotto questo video mi
raccomando beh beh chi sa cosa c'è
la diffusione si vede la tv il segreto
del caffè ma sicuramente un tempo non
c'era ovviamente la tv ma perché non
esisteva uniti per che cosa c'è una
finestra verso un'altra parte del
cartello forse delle segrete magari
riusciranno scoprirlo non credo però
fossero le seguirebbe perché perché
effettivamente sono segrete nessuno le
ho viste ro pa
sa qual è la parte che vi piace di più
dalla nostra camera del castello un
indeciso la poltrona da regina era che
noi aderiamo le cose paurose inquietanti
quindi questa stanza è perfetta perché
mi hanno un po inquietante sembra che
nasconda qualche strano segreto ma forse
se devo scegliere la smetti di costanzo
questi si devono nascondere e sempre
solido forse la mia cosa preferita è la
vista da questo stampa verso il cortile
del castello
poi domani con i soliti faremo vedere
meglio e questo che cos'è è uno sgabello
non mi ero accorta che ci fossero uno
sgabello qua quelle sgabello e stato
messo a posto di positi poi se deve
ammirare il bellissimo paesaggio che si
vede dalla finestra
beh cerchiamo di sopravvivere per ora la
prima notte nel castello sono a vivere
ma io già lo adoro il re mi ha dato due
cioccolatini a prendermi volta
il mago io sono sicuro di una cosa cosa
vitale in qualche modo che questi
scrivete nei commenti dove devo
nascondere questi cioccolatini in modo
che vitali non li trovi forse
nell'armadio inquietante forse nella
feritoia potevano sapere nei commenti
così lo posso scoprire andar lì e
mangiare ovviamente lascio più mi piace
è stato questo che ci vediamo molto per
tempo che ha tempestato di fantasmi ciao
ciao
[Musica]